[Music]
electric universe indeed the entire
mathematical establishment believes that
light is an electromagnetic wave the
mathematicians routinely illustrate
their abstract wave as a bunch of
mutually perpendicular lines
the mathematical wave consists of an
electric field and a magnetic field in
this scheme of things wavelength is
defined as the horizontal distance
between Peaks and amplitude as the
vertical distance between Peaks the
electromagnetic wave of the religion of
mathematical physics travels one way in
a single direction and for never
explained reasons oscillates around an
axis frequency is defined as the number
of Peaks per second
physics however is first and foremost
the study of objects we cannot do
physics without objects what would there
be to study what would there be to see
what experiment can you run without an
object even thought experiments are done
with images unfortunately for our
misguided mathematicians there is no
object in physics called a wave wave is
not what something is but what something
does the wave of mathematics is not a
noun but a verb likewise there is no
object in physics known as a field the
word field is also a concept and as such
it doesn't belong in physics as a
physical object
if light interacts with matter we have
no choice but to replace the abstract
wave of mathematics with a physical
entity the trick is to break the code to
discover the correct configuration of
the entity that underlies the phenomenon
we call light it is thus that we replace
the mathematical wave with a physical
rope like mediator the wave is alleged
to consist of a magnetic field and an
electric field the physical
electromagnetic rope is comprised
instead of a magnetic thread and an
electric thread the wavelength of
mathematics now becomes the length of a
link and the ropes amplitude is given by
the height of the threads the anti
parallel threads of a taut rope have no
choice but to coil around an imaginary
axis whereas mathematical waves travel
in a single direction torsion along the
rope travels in both directions
simultaneously the rope and the wave
come to a head when trying to explain
physical phenomena for instance the
mathematical establishment has no idea
what physically restrains light to a
constant speed as specified by its very
own wave equation why does frequency go
up when the wavelength goes down and
vice-versa here we have six waves each
one centimeter long passing a given
point in one second what physical reason
is therefore the frequency to drop to
three waves per second when wavelength
increases to two centimeters what
physically prevents both the wavelength
and the frequency from increasing so
that light can travel faster
under the rope model of light the longer
you make the links the fewer links you
can fit in any given length of rope the
rope model justifies why frequency and
wavelength are inversely proportional
and why light is a constant Maxwell's
equation is the equation of a rope the
mathematicians also have no clue why the
speed of light is independent of the
speed of its source the reason so many
mathematicians today still search for
speeds faster than light is that they
see no reason why the two speeds
shouldn't be added logic would suggest
that the light is traveling at the speed
of light for the torch
but then I need to add on 140 miles an
hour with the Train is going under the
rope model when an atom is approaching
another one it reels in the
electromagnetic threads which now form
part of its body an atom slides along
any given rope like a bead on an abacus
this is how Mother Nature secretly does
this magic trick under the rope model of
light there is no mystery as to why the
speed of light is independent of the
speed of the source to make matters
bleaker for the quantum wave and atom
allegedly manufactures light when the
electron bead quantum jumps this signal
energy radiation or whatever travels off
to nowhere and comes from nowhere a
pertinent question then is whether a
wave manufactured in an atom of the
Andromeda galaxy travels like a sailboat
include a cosmic ocean all the way to
earth or extends from there all the way
to here where does the mathematical wave
begin where does it end under the rope
model an atom in the Andromeda galaxy is
permanently bound to any atom comprising
the solar system the electromagnetic
rope interconnects any two atoms in the
universe torsion has no chance of
getting lost irrespective of where an
atom moves whereas quantum mechanics
proposes that atoms are discrete
independent
entities the rope hypothesis proposes
that all atoms in the universe are
interconnected
what is
plexi is that there are people out there
who still don't understand the
difference between an object and a
concept as far as all these neophytes
are concerned all we did was assign a
new name to the infamous field of
mathematics so let's clarify the
difference field is a concept a thread
is a physical object a thread physically
binds two atoms to each other a concept
such as field is like the concepts love
and information concepts cannot pull two
atoms together or perform any operations
in the physical world
therefore it is ludicrous for the
mathematicians to claim at this late
stage in the game that light is a wave
which is comprised of two fields neither
wave nor field as a place in physics
in the religion of mathematical physics
and electron orbits the nucleus the
mathematicians have reengineered this
atom over the years and today claim that
the electron is really a fuzzy cloud
that envelopes the nucleus so this is a
very good picture of a hydrogen atom
with an electron in the lowest energy
state the electron occupies a cloud
instead of an orbit but this is a
circular argument because the
mathematicians allege that this cloud is
a region where we can find an electron
now what's a cloud a cloud is an area
where the there's the most probability
of finding an electron imagine that we
take a picture of this electron every
second for a day a week or a month you
see that all these pictures laid on top
of one another
begin to form an electron cloud around
the nucleus remember all these
hypothetical pictures or data points
represent where the electron has been
over time so the electron Abid that
orbits the nucleus a cloud that
envelopes the nucleus or is a cloud a
region around the nucleus where we can
find the electron what cloud of
electrons can a hydrogen atom have if it
has a single electron
under the rope hypothesis the atom
finally receives a rational physical
interpretation the electric and magnetic
threads fork at the boundary of an atom
the electric thread continues straight
to the center of the atom and out the
other end
the magnetic thread meanwhile curves
around and forms the electron shell the
electric threads from every atom in the
universe converge upon a given atom
forming an urchin like star at its
center
meanwhile the magnetic threads weave the
electron shell that encapsulate s' the
proton thus the atom is not comprised
simultaneously of an orbiting bead which
is actually a cloud which is actually a
region where we can find the electron
bead the atom is an urchin like star
encapsulated within a cell the surface
of which resembles a ball of yarn when
the atom contracts it releases links of
rope radially and when the atom expands
it draws in thread to make up for the
larger atom the so-called quantum jump
torques the rope the atom is a little
heart pumping torsion waves called light
- every atom in the universe
[Music]
[Music]